and school bus online c-span school bus
org you know Eric Alterman when we ask
you to come to the program this morning
it was to react to yesterday's last
night's speech and the convention but
your new book showed up but at the
offices here and I I really want to ask
you about this book because it's kind of
a bipartisan accusation about lying
president's lying what's the point of
when presidents lie well I wouldn't call
it an accusation Brian I would call it a
history it's I started this book 11
years ago before even President Clinton
was called a liar by anyone of
significance and it was intended to be a
pragmatic argument for truth in other
words everybody knows that lying is
wrong
most people lie anyway most presidents
certainly lie anyway and I had the idea
that it was a bad idea that it didn't
work well that they would be better off
personally politically and certainly
patriotically if they told the truth and
I tested that by examining for
consequential lies what I call lies well
not actually their lives they're not
what I call it I was very careful to
pick examples where no one could argue
that it wasn't a lie
President Roosevelt's description of
what he did at the Yalta Conference
which is something that drove
conservators crazy for decades in this
country John Kennedy's description
refusal to disclose the deal that he
made and the Cuban Missile Crisis
President Johnson's miss portrayal of
what happened to talk and golf in August
of 1964 and Ronald Reagan's Central
America policy which led to the around
Contra scandal and then I finish up by
comparing in president george w bush's
lies and mistruths and misleading x'
that mislead the country into this
catastrophic war word now let me ask you
about that so you were the first numbers
were all Democrats then you got to
Ronald Reagan and then George W Bush
John Kerry have you seen him lie at all
during this campaign
not that I've been able to discern Oh
how do you find I mean one little note
on your story about FDR is the the
Doctor Who gave reports at that time to
the American people about his condition
and that seemed you consider that a lie
no I mean I don't actually tell you the
truth I don't remember exactly what the
doctor said well enough to tell you
whether or not he was truthful but I
don't that's not a significant issue in
fact I don't even take issue with John
Kennedy's refusal to reveal his medical
condition or his sex life I try to play
pay pay very close attention to
consequential laws of state and you know
it is that you're right it is a
bipartisan book and there's more there's
far more fault found with Democrats than
with Republicans in this book one thing
that I suppose people who are looking
for a political angle to this book will
say as well you spent a lot of time on
President Reagan and you are very
critical of President Bush and I am
critical of him for lying and for a lot
of other reasons but you don't spend any
time on Bill Clinton who lied it's true
I don't spend any time on Bill Clinton
and I also don't spend any time when
Richard Nixon is probably the most
famous presidential liar
even though Arnold Schwarzenegger
apparently is a great admirer of his and
invented a debate that he imagined he
had with Hubert Humphrey the other night
and the reason I left out Nixon was
because everybody knows that story this
story is about the consequences of law
it's not just I'm interesting liar liar
liar I'm saying here's what happens to
our society our implicit our political
community when you tell a lie and why it
turns out not to work well with Bill
Clinton I have to tell you I'm not very
critical of a man who lies about his sex
life to protect his family I think
everybody has that right I think
everybody I think it's a it's a it's
almost uncivilized not to lie about your
sex life and the fact that Clinton had a
70 million-dollar investigation to
determine whether or not he was telling
the truth about his sex life is
something that Bush I'm far more
critical and
and it's unprecedented in American
history I mean if you wanted if I were
writing a book about presidential sex
lives well I would have to write about
extramarital affairs of all just about
all these people I think um certainly
Franklin Roosevelt Eisenhower was
famously had a had a is is I don't know
it for certain so I won't say it started
but it's most historians I think except
that Eisenhower was not had had these
issues certainly John Kennedy certainly
Lyndon Johnson I don't know about Nixon
Ronald Reagan's written on the front
page of the New York Times that that was
it Ronald Reagan see I'm not gonna get
into this I'm gonna take that back
because I don't remember the point is is
that if you looked into the sex lives of
presidents you would find an enormous
amount of the kinds of things that were
on the front page of the newspapers for
Bill Clinton alone and and if you look
at the statistics of people who are who
say they've committed adultery been
unfaithful to their husbands or wives
its enormous it's it's it's it's in case
of men I think it's over fifty percent
so the fact what distinguishes Clinton
was that he was telling a private lie
these are lies to the country lies
usually in in every case actually about
warrant piece in the roosevelt case it
was about diplomacy but it was about
it'll-it'll ed in many ways for the kind
of cold war that we had and that's when
I think we elect presidents to do we
elect presidents primarily to conduct
foreign policy they dealt in in domestic
policy there's a whole Congress there's
all these states there's a federal
system that prevents them from getting
much done unless the country supports it
but in foreign policy they can pretty
much do what they want and if they lie
to us then there's absolutely no way to
check whether or not we're doing what
they're doing with ourselves all right
let me ask you this and we'll go the
phones in about three or four minutes
but let me ask you they did they
purposely lied they know they're lying
or is this after the fact looking back
saying clearly somebody in that mix
wasn't telling the truth no you see the
media I quote Ben Bradley in this in
this book saying that no journalists
will ever say the president said XYZ
last night he was lying and so the media
confused this issue because they're
unwilling to call the president alarm
Dana Millbank was one of the
toughest reporters on President Bush
wrote a front-page story long before we
went to Iraq in the Washington Post in
which he used every conceivable synonym
for the world lied that you could use
without calling Bush a liar Bush is a
liar Bush deliberately misled the
country he knew what he was saying is
not true
the same goes for Roosevelt the same
goes for Johnson the same goes for
Reagan and the same goes for Kennedy in
these in these instances now it's
complicated it's not it's not
questionable I I don't think for
instance that Lyndon Johnson lied on
August 4th 1964 when he said that the
United States had been attacked in the
Gulf of Tonkin I don't think he knew the
truth and what had happened but he knew
a few days later and by that time he
decided it was too late to tell the
truth and so the entire effort of the
Vietnam War was built on a on an untruth
that was originally accidental but
became a lie in order to for Johnson to
protect his short-term political
interest in almost every one of these
cases the president is protecting what
they deemed to be their short-term
political interest in fact Bush's and it
is an exception because Bush was lying
to take the country to war which was
very risky Twisp all you thinking he
knew he was lying at the time when he
Gorge Bush I don't think he cared
um I think Bush felt like he knew a
higher truth you know there's that
conversation where he tells Bob Woodward
but Weaver says why didn't you ask your
father about this because he's had a lot
of experience it's kind of thing he went
to war in fact was thought I was saying
and Bush said well my father is
accountable is is I didn't want any weak
advice I was speaking to a higher father
I think Bush is a political fanatic be
it for religious reasons or audiological
reasons or because his advisors have
gotten a hold of him and he was not
interested in the truth he didn't seek
the truth he didn't care when I mean I
can give you instances where Bush has
clearly lied he said we have found
weapons of mass destructions in Iraq
that's clearly false Bush has twice said
that he had to invade Iraq because
Saddam Hussein would not allow the
weapons inspectors in he said it twice
okay clearly the weapons backers were in
there and they had to be forced out in
order for us to invade Iraq he has on
many occasions
things which are patently false now are
you asking me do I know what's in his
head how can I know what's in his head
I'm saying I knew what he was saying at
the time was false and he's the
president the United States how could he
not know and also how could Cheney not
now
how could pal not now how could Rumsfeld
not now how could
Paul Wolfowitz not now how could condi
rice Sanya they knew if they didn't know
there they're so incompetent it's it's
impossible to imagine we're gonna have
that another point of view from the
other side of the discussion John putt
hearts will be with us for a full hour
from 9:00 until 10:00 to make some of
our viewers even more uncomfortable with
your point of view on the media Fox News
a huge winner got more viewers on
Wednesday night than ABC and CBS
combined Fox News Channel on cable oh
yeah it doesn't even go to all the home
right how does that make you feel well
it frustrates me I mean it's a historic
event but I'll be honest it frustrates
me in my view of the media is that and
I've written as you know you've had me
on before for my book what liberal media
my view of the media is that there is a
conservative media which is represented
by Fox News in the Wall Street Journal
editorial page and the Weekly Standard
and Rush Limbaugh and all of talk radio
and most of cable TV and then there's a
mainstream media which is competing with
the conservative media for those viewers
Fox is taking viewers away from the
mainstream media and and the
Conservatives have a brilliant public
relations gambit they call it working
the refs where they continually accuse
the mainstream media of being liberal in
order to get it to be more and more
conservative when in fact there are very
few liberals in the so-called liberal
media and and almost no representation I
mean if you take a perfect example the
New York Times is always considered
ground zero of the liberal media well if
the New York Times were a liberal media
why would they have to apologize for
Judy Miller and other reporters hyping
this issue of weapons of mass
destruction on behalf of the
administration why would the most
important liberal newspaper in the
country be the one that was in fact the
most influential newspaper in passing
along these falsehoods about what the
Bush administration wanted the country
to believe Erica
has a lot of degrees a PhD now from
Stanford even asked me about that for a
long I've been waiting to come here we
got it this year this is your
dissertation right here on the table
here coming out September the 29th in
the bookstores Yale University masters
in international relations 86 Cornell
University Ithaca New York BA in history
and government 1982 how old is your son
my daughter Eve Rose there was a dog oh
my daughter Rose beautiful talented
heroes Alterman is six years old she's
going into first grade in PS 87 next
year let's go to Kennesaw Georgia John
Kerry supporter for Eric Alterman good
morning good morning
I've got a cold so I don't sound very
good but I thank you for writing that
book maybe throwing people will demand
more from their presidents in regard to
President Bush she continues lying
singing he's made the world a favourite
place when indeed he hasn't by going
into Iraq like he did without a
coalition and I don't call 40 people
from from Poland a coalition who are
driving the trucks he has created a
situation where al Qaeda will probably
recruit a lot of people so instead of
making the world safer he has made it
more dangerous but you make a very
interesting point you know um I was on a
panel at the new school in New York City
and a professor next to me said that the
media had suppressed the fact that Bush
was warned by the CIA that there was no
terrorist threat to United States
emanating from Iraq but that if he
invaded Iraq that that would likely
inspire one so we were safer now than we
would be in the event of the invasion
that he was planning and this was known
to Bush and it was it was presented to
him by the CIA and I said to the
gentleman next to me who said it do you
know where that information was
suppressed and he says no I don't
understand what you mean and I said it
was suppressed on the front page of the
New York Times in other words I read
that story on the front page of the New
York Times I knew it but the political
system didn't take it into account
because if you knew that one simple fact
if you knew that
there wasn't any terrorism coming out of
Iraq all this stuff about Iraq and al
Qaeda was made up Dick Cheney
was flying lying then then there was no
reason to invade wrecked a new invasion
made absolutely no sense except as an
ideological project of any of
conservatives now the thing is we did
know it it was on the front page of New
York Times but because of the power of
the Conservatives in the media like Fox
News like Rush Limbaugh like The Wall
Street Journal editorial page that fact
never had any salience all the only
facts that were consider important were
the facts that the ministration was
pushing and so stories had called into
question as as Len Downey has admitted
for instance in the Washington Post the
executive or the watch most were shunted
off to page a17
but the stories that were gung-ho on
behalf of the bush administration those
were always on page a1 and picked up by
the cable stations and then Network News
Greenville South Carolina go ahead
please you're on with Eric Alterman good
morning c-span morning your guest made a
comment that that the only thing that
Bill Clinton lied about was sex well
everyone in this country has a right and
it's a very dear write of having a free
trial or trial that's protected a trial
and truth that matter that he lied about
was about somebody who brought up a
during a trial a charge and you're
supposed to get truth in a in a in a
jury or in a trial and Bill Clinton lied
now there's only one precious right we
get and it's right to be heard in a
trial of our peers and a jury with truth
in it and Bill Clinton the chief
executive of our company of our of our
country lied during that process where
he's supposed to hold the truth if
anybody's supposed to hold the truth
it's the president United States under
oath during a trial where every citizen
even the lowest citizen which Democrats
are supposed to protect the low in this
country they should be protected by
having a right would be having a
truthful and everybody should not lie
during a trial and well sir I know I
don't know I don't spend any time on
Clinton in the book so I don't really
want to get this kind of a tangent for
me from the perspective of what I want
to talk about just personally I consider
it you know the thousand where we've
lost about a thousand soldiers in Iraq
those soldiers all have mothers and
fathers they have children
I think that their parents and their
children who've lost their lost their
children would say it's far more
consequential that the president and
vice president deliberately misled this
country into war then President Clinton
lied about his personal sex life you and
I just disagree on that you know
speaking of the media coming up very
soon unless something very different
happens there will be the one-thousandth
death in Iraq what would you suggest at
this point how big a deal will the media
make out of it is that the kind of thing
that would be front-page news will there
be a discussion about it you know so
often we go after stories that revolve
around numbers yeah no I think it'll be
a one-day story because it doesn't fit
well with the conservative playbook I
think that the conservatives are driving
our discourse today with very little
resistance from the mainstream media you
know all of this Swift boat stuff is a
very good example I wrote my column on
the Nation about it this week everyone
in the media knows that what they're
saying is not true it's all been there
hasn't been a single allegation that
they've made that's been documented
whereas Kerry has been able to document
his response and yet occasionally in
22nd paragraph of a very long story the
media will mention that oh by the way
this isn't true but they play it all
according to well he said she said the
bush team said the Swift boaters say
their carrier team responds and they
don't really not really interested in
whether or not the thing is true and
that plays enormous ly to the advantage
of the people who are doing the lying
and if you look at the if in some cases
it's just laziness in some cases it's
it's the the sort of anthropology in the
media and in some cases it's deliberate
dishonesty at the part of it Robert
Novak for instance on CNN called these
people the real heroes of the campaign
without telling his viewers that his own
son is in charge of publicity for the
publisher Regnery I mean really I really
think that the standards of the media
have fallen so low in this campaign that
that the the it calls them to question
our ability to have an honest election
are you still a senior fellow at the
Center for American Progress
I am proud seeing a fella run by its the
president is John Podesta who was who
was chief of staff and two
Greensburg Pennsylvania you're on the
air thank you for taking my call
kudos to uh I guess now dr. Alterman I
hope I hope in your book you point out
that the president has gotten a pass in
in recent months just fluffing off you
know criticism of the voting bill
country into war by you know as the
president some are being a victim of bad
intelligence regarding weapons of mass
destruction programs the President and
Vice President made completely
unsupported statements regarding Iraq's
supposed nuclear weapons programs he
treated them to the International Atomic
Energy Agency the documents he he cited
didn't exist yeah pick up on that for a
second thank you very much um I I
co-authored a book that came out earlier
this year called the book on Bush this
is it if you want to say I just came in
paperback and which I drew from from
which I drew for the what when
presidents lie on the bush section now I
wrote this book last summer there's
sections on Iraq and in that book I was
able to tell that there wasn't very good
evidence that the that Iraq had these
weapons of mass destruction and I was
using US government sources people who
studies by the State Department
Department of intelligence and research
the Pentagon's own intelligence service
people who retired from these service
general Anthony Zinni who was head of
Central Command in even fat Colin Powell
said so two years before we invaded and
it was evident to me that at best they
had no idea at best that that their that
all of these statements that Bush and
Cheney were always making in Rumsfeld we
absolutely positively and Powell who to
me has has forfeited his reputation as
an honest man um that they couldn't
support them that they didn't know that
the Germans and French who were saying
no let's wait let's see what we can do
maybe we can work this out without war
we're absolutely right
I knew it okay I don't have access to
classified information I just read
carefully and ignored the propaganda
smoke from cable TV and network TV and
the front pages the newspapers so when
when Bush says to me I couldn't possibly
know I was misled by the CIA I'm saying
you active
chose to be misled to CI because we
wanted this war regardless of whether or
not there was evidence and again I hold
the media responsible for not pointing
that out because if I could do what they
could have done it I'll come back to you
on this but of all the lies that you
wrote about in your book which one was
the most egregious in your opinion gee I
don't know I guess I don't want to read
which one was the most deliberate I mean
if somebody clearly decide to lie on
purpose to bring about a certain
reaction from the heart well you have to
talk about when you're his story and you
have to pay attention to historical
context so I understand why franklin
roosevelt didn't want to tell the truth
about the Ault agreement and i
understand why john kennedy felt he
needed to sell the Cuban Missile Crisis
solution the way he did I have very
little sympathy for what Lyndon Johnson
did with regard to Vietnam again but he
he didn't lie in the first place the
person who was actually most culpable
for the Vietnam law for the Tonkin Gulf
lie that Johnson told his McNamara
although because it was McNamara who
misinformed president and the president
told what he thought was the truth on
that night and then found himself caught
up on a lie and never bothered to get
out from under it although Johnson was a
famously inveterate liar and so I don't
think that was really he was really
concerned about that too much
um in the case of Reagan and Bush Ronald
Reagan and George W Bush in both of
those cases they were lying on behalf of
a project that they sought out that the
country didn't support in other words
Reagan wanted to fight these wars in
Central America and and Bush wanted to
go to war in Iraq and the only way they
could convince the country to go along
with them was to mislead it was to say
it's really something that it isn't
and I firstly fine taking the country to
war under false circumstances to be the
most egregious now it's true Johnson -
the same thing so it's probably it's
probably just as offensive I have a
feeling we would have gone to war over
Vietnam whether or not Johnson lied
about talking so for Aaron Carter when
we go to Hemet California a good morning
Hemet California are you there let's go
to Chicago Illinois Chicago are you
there
Chicago is at you please go ahead
Chicago let's go on to the next call we
have please on the rack down in
Washington whatever it is where you
calling from caller sir we can hear you
would you please go ahead Thank You mr.
Lam and thank you see spin I know you've
heard of repeatedly and repeatedly but
to us c-span Attucks we really
appreciate the coverage especially the
coverage of the protest was I found very
interesting we can't find that anywhere
on mainstream TV but you can bring all
all the intellectuals you want on mr.
Lam from both sides but when you give me
that statistic that I heard that Fox
News is going through the roof I'm
afraid sir this country we're in deep
deep trouble sir you can bring all the
intellectuals you want on but when you
bring on this news about Fox News I'm
afraid this country is in a downward
spiral sir and we're in deep deep
trouble that's a matter of President
Bush's elected reelected what doesn't
matter this country's in serious trouble
okay thanks but let me ask Eric Alterman
if you look at these numbers the New
York Times has in the paper this morning
this is from Wednesday night that the
Fox had 5.9 million viewers CBS 2.6 ABC
3.3 NBC 4.5 you add that up that's about
15 million you throw in our viewers and
PBS and all you might have you might
have 20 million people watching right a
294 million people do you grid download
how many of those viewers you think are
undecided
damn few I'm betting that whatever does
that poll by the way right but that's
why that's why people say even a lot of
my liberal friends and intellectual
friends say then I waste my time
focusing so much on the media and that I
you know it's really about fundamental
differences between the two parties well
yes the two parties are fundamentally
different in my view but I think the
media is how people experience or our
politics that they don't actually see
very much but people don't watch the
conventions the the
network news gets about 30 million at
night total but there's very little
actual news in the network news anymore
it's all about Lacey Peterson or
Patterson or whatever that is and and so
the news just sort of filters down to
people you know they watch Comedy
Central or they watched a Leno or they
don't watch anything or they hear it on
talk radio and I think the media is the
media are actually are politics and so I
pay enormous attention to how these
things are portrayed and I think with a
few exceptions I'll give you one
exception Paul Krugman the columnist New
York Times writes about this a lot I
think the media are incapable of
portraying the differences between the
Republicans and Democrats because the
Republicans are kind of a stealth party
you saw it this week you saw them having
Rudy Giuliani whose main positions are
repudiated by most of the Republican
Party same with Arnold Schwarzenegger
same with Michael Bloomberg who is all
is a Republican her name only
you see same with John McCain John
McCain is saying to the president please
repudiate these Swift Boat ads the
president won't do it and he had John
McCain who's a is the big single biggest
serial to the media anywhere is still
hugging President Clinton a President
Bush and endorsing him the media are not
capable of demonstrating just how
radical the Republican Party has become
the real party is the party of Tom DeLay
and and of the neoconservatives of the
Christian Right it's not the party of
Arnold Schwarzenegger and John McCain
and yet that's what we get and so I
think it's really important to call the
media to account for this because
they're really running interference for
people I don't you know Al Gore won the
popular vote back in 2000 by 500,000
votes when people thought George Bush
was a moderate compassionate
conservative now that we know that
George Bush is a right-wing radical I
think we should have an entirely
different kind of political discussion
and yet we're not having it Rush
Limbaugh disagrees with you in The Wall
Street Journal is smart Oh in the mall
Street Journal he calls it about a
moderate myth the common in fact the
universal analysis surrounding the
Republican National Convention was that
the president was showing showcasing
moderates like new Rudy Giuliani Arnold
Schwarzenegger and a populist like John
McCain of course it wasn't that long ago
when each of these men was horribly
maligned by the same media that now
holds him
proving ly a centrist mr. Giuliani is a
heartless mayor hell-bent on cleaning up
New York streets mr. sweren
Schwarzenegger is in Austria Austrian
immigrant stop right there where are his
examples what he nobody he says that
they were the media were doing this but
does he have any actual examples John
McCain has always been a hero to the
media Rudy Giuliani it's true he was uh
he was a very difficult man to have
mayor as New York but he had very good
relations for the media for a long time
and after 9/11 there hasn't been a
critical word written about you Rudy
Giuliani just about anywhere he was a
hero to me on that day I thought a nun a
liberal I thought he he was wonderful
Arnold Schwarzenegger has gotten a very
nice ride from media this is what the
conservatives do Brian they do it all
the time they say look the media is so
hard on these people they're giving
Republicans such as a tough time but in
fact the media's been pussycats to these
people and this is exactly the kind of
working the refs right wing analysis you
could suspect from both watch Limbaugh
and the Wall Street Journal
Rush Limbaugh writes in The Wall Street
Journal today well let me suggest that
the media have it all wrong they don't
understand the Republican Party they
don't understand conservatism and they
don't understand President Bush I agree
with him about that next it's right
about that next call show only thing
he's right about Chicago you're on with
Eric although Rush oh hi my name oh yeah
well I'm calling chiefly because my
chief complaint and I guess it's I guess
it's a lie that is to say that Bush
doesn't know how to pronounce nuclear
you know not only does he not know how
to pronounce it but many of your people
who are supposed experts in in nuclear
technology do not know how to pronounce
it
have you seen sir have you seen that
video have you seen the video of this
land is your land with my flim-flam
where Bush and Kerry are singing at each
other and Kerry's things - Bush it's to
the land of it's to the tune of this
land is your land
and and the Kerry figures things you
can't say nuclear that really scares me
sometimes the brain might come in real
handy
don't see why you're upset about it I'll
tell you the truth Jimmy Carter couldn't
say no Jimmy Carter was an engineer and
he couldn't say nuclear either so what I
mean of all the things to be upset about
George Bush with the fact that I can't
say nuclear is about well number 1
million and 10 on the list
thanks to my car from Chicago and that
reminds me I heard an anchor on one of
the cable channels the other night
referring to would take you now to a
current Ohio can I say I want to fob the
other car c-span doesn't get enough
credit I started this book 11 years ago
I've been on the show I was on the show
you did book notes with me for my very
first book which came out in 1992 it's
still the best interview did anybody
ever did for me on a book I'm really
sorry that you're giving up book notes I
understand that it was very demanding
and it's up 20 hours and I appreciate
that you're the only guy who actually
reads books that you interview people
about but it's really that if you look
at the past 12 years since you did that
interview with me the television news
has gotten so much worse it's gotten so
much more difficult to express a
coherent thought to give to to challenge
the context of anything that we are fed
by this right-wing driven media machine
and that this is really such a valuable
a SISO grateful to you not only for
doing it but also for fighting for it
because I know that the cable system
hasn't made it easy on you Jacksonville
Florida you're on with Eric Alterman go
ahead please Eric you're a good man
but I won't say every time I listen to
push I put a lot the comfortable
statement of possible poverty in AC and
I carry it everywhere I go because I
look at it and I said you guys been
planning this here since 1972 they
organized in 1970 1997 and no one seemed
to want to talk about this but this
almost 10 years almost close to 12 years
to attack the midis yeah I I think you
make a strong point now the President
Bush did this last night I didn't see
the speech but I read it this morning I
wanted to experience it the way most
Americans experience it which is to
ignore it when it happens and just let
it waft into me but I did notice very
high up in the coverage that they that
Bush said something to the degree of
well the terrorist attack
and this taught us that we had to take
the war right to the terrorists and
Cheney says this all the time but in
fact 9/11 was entirely irrelevant to the
war in Iraq except as a means except
that Bush was able to exploit it to put
into place this plan that had been
hatched long before 9/11 by a variety of
neoconservative organizations there are
actually three different versions of it
and if you recall on September 15 2001
Dick Cheney said let's look into
attacking Iraq having no evidence
whatsoever and they never did turn up
any evidence that um that Iraq was
involved so again if I lost someone I
know people I didn't lose anyone thank
goodness on 9/11 that was very close to
me but I know a lot of people who did
and I know that an awful lot of 9/11
families are just furious with the way
that their tragedy has been exploited
for a war that had incontestably nothing
whatsoever to do with it here's the
cover of a new book coming out by Eric
Haldeman it was his dissertation at
Stanford when President sly you know
there's just a small subtle layer on the
cover this flag on the a pal did you did
you have your publisher do that on
purpose they they gave me that design
and I thought it was great who said
let's go with it I really like that pin
because it's a patriotic book it's a
book that argues that both presidents
and the country would be better off if
we would all just tell the truth that
believe it or not honesty is genuinely
the best policy I do want to just make
one clarification the first two chapters
of this book are drawn from my doctoral
dissertation in history at Stanford but
it's not a dissertation that would be
boring people wouldn't like that the
second half was written just for this
book and I rewrote the first two
chapters to make them more fun Fort
Wayne Indiana good morning you're on
with Eric alderman a George Bush
supporter I really do support the
president I would never support you sir
in a million years I have a Nestor's I
haven't read your book but I can tell by
the way you're talking I wouldn't I will
never buy it you're too liberal too
biased and when you tell me the press
isn't biased the only lies that are
coming out are the ones right out of
your mouth
I hope my mother's not seeing I mean
what can I say you know I this book has
I think a hundred and forty pages of
footnotes something like 115 pages with
us
there isn't a sentence in this book that
isn't supported by evidence you can
disagree with my politics most people do
I'm fine with that but the way I've
tried to make my way in this world to
stake my reputation is that when I say
something I can back it up with evidence
if I said something that I can't back up
with evidence I'll tell you as I did
earlier in the show when I started to
say something that I decided I shouldn't
say because I can't support so if you
want to argue with me ma'am argue with
my evidence don't argue with my politics
because my politics are not the point
the point is I backed up the fact that
all of these presidents lied three of
them are Democrats two of them are
Republicans if you don't like that fine
don't buy my book I can't live without
you but I don't think I don't think the
marketers actually planned for you to
buy my book one day when I put it out
this published by Viking in the New York
Times this morning there are two
articles on the media one of them is a
article by Alessandra Stanley about Fox
News she says there this has not been an
angry week for the network however Fox
News is rating soared during the
Republican convention
later on she says but for the most part
Fox reporters reported by the book and
the convention coverage has not proved
any different one will go to the
network's White House correspondent
reported yesterday morning about
President Bush's endorsement from New
York firefighters on Wednesday and then
noted that John Kerry had won the
support of their national organization
Fox anchors and commentators have more
license to speak their minds well I find
it very difficult to tell the difference
between Fox anchors and commentators and
reporters for all I know what she's
saying is true I watched this
documentary that's being distributed by
move on comm that was supported by the
Center for American Progress and move on
called outfoxed by Robert Greenwald
which you can order if you want to see
it from moveon.org Lujan darknet with
another and it demonstrated I think
beyond the doubt that Fox deliberately
distorts the news and in fact there is a
memo that's put out every day by mr.
moody at fonts which tells that everyone
how they're gonna play the news that day
so if it's something that's going to
help the Bush administration they'll
play it one way if it's something that's
not gonna help the Bush Bush
commissioners they'll play it another
way
can I just interrupt saying isn't it
fair in this discussion to note that
Robert Greenwald is clearly a political
documentary producer easy as a point of
view and that moveon.org and that your
centre is involved in this so they're
naturally going to look at Fox News and
say listen this is a very important
theological point it's very important
yes we all have a point of view yes you
have a point of view even though you
hide it better than most um the point is
is that a let's be open about our point
of view which I certainly am but B let's
talk about the evidence in other words
Greenwald has compiled the evidence he
has he has Bill O'Reilly distorting he's
got the memos there in Harper's Magazine
this month if you want to buy Harper's
you can read the memos or you can read
them online that doesn't matter the same
thing has been done for years by the
Conservatives who go after the
mainstream media and say they're liberal
but yeah but I'm saying let's examine
the evidence and see who's got a better
case I think if you examine the evidence
say of my book what liberal media which
has a over 1,500 footnotes or over a
thousand footnotes and the evidence
presented by my opponents say bernard
goldberg or and cult or any one of those
people you'll say one of these books is
supported by footnotes and has evidence
and one of these books doesn't and
therefore if I'm if I'm a person who's
looking to make up my mind then I'm
gonna say well how does this person
support their allegations Alterman has
it and these people don't that's why I
think it's it's not a fair fight because
the media isn't interested in evidence
the media is interested in just he-said
she-said without getting to the bottom
of the truth if they did get to the
bottom of the truth these got these
Swift voter guys couldn't be able to get
arrested
instead of dominating the election and
possibly changing the outcome by the way
the wall street journal' nonfiction
bestseller list today shows unfit for
command by John O'Neill number one and
American so do you remember five years
ago number do you remember four years
ago when somebody published a book I
think was called fortunate son that had
an unsupported allegation that George
Bush did Covello from Texas yeah that
book was withdrawn it was condemned by
everyone alive and the allegations were
not taken seriously even though they may
be true they were
unproven these Swift voters have been
fruit discredited just as profoundly as
that book and yet everybody acts like
it's so important why is God twice
Marinette Georgia for Eric alderman good
morning good morning Brian
I just had a couple points um every time
I see like President Bush going to a
like the veterans and whatever you see
people in uniform they're probably
active duty and I always thought that
you're not supposed to wear your uniform
to a rally or a protest I actually wrote
about this this week on my website for
MSNBC which is called altercation you
can find it at dub dub dub altercation
msnbc.com
and I originally was concerned because
the the Republican Party announced that
they had 3% active-duty military serving
as delegates and I know that it's not
it's it's forbidden by the military code
of conduct to participate in political
activity of that nature
under active duty now it turned out a
friend of mine named major Bob Bateman
send me an email said no Eric you should
have checked with me and he's right
these guys are reserves and reserves are
allowed to participate and active duty
or not so depending on the depending on
the circumstance you're talking about
they're not allowed to participate
actively in politics while on if they're
in active duty as opposed to being in
the reserves now what I do think you
might be seeing I don't know exactly the
examples talking about but I do think
you might be seeing is that the the
networks and cable news has been
egregious about this have a loud Bush to
use the military basically as a prop
that every time Bush gives a speech
before the military it's carried live
it's basically a campaign speech he says
the same thing that he said before a lot
of which is not true and they just
basically turned over their networks to
the president now and I'm Brian I'm not
making this up there's been studies by
fair that have been publicized by the
Center for American Progress that
demonstrate that there's an enormous
imbalance between not only the way Bush
gets covered and his opponent John Kerry
but where the way Bush gets covered and
by the way President Clinton gets
covered and it's not just on Fox
it's CNN too Bush has been masterful at
manipulating the media
and the media have just have not stood
up to Gainesville Virginia good morning
good morning I know that anything that I
say won't influence or change Eric's
mind on anything I think probably much
of his motivations driven like a lot I
believe those that disagree with Bush
and want him out by hatred that really
probably cannot be stopped in any way
but I guess I just want to ask you a
question and then I'll let you go on I
just went to a question you've never met
me you don't know me how can you
possibly go on a national TV program and
tell people what is motivating me well
you've only heard me talk for 20 minutes
do I am I do I go around telling people
what makes you do what you do why in the
world would you it should be
psychological motivations to me oh okay
okay that was all right that's unfair
all right that's unfair let let me
continue
I just I'm saying I'm saying that I want
to say that yes if President Bush set
out to lie and this was his motivation
was to lie to the American people and to
bring us to this war then he had a lot
of accomplices and I was watching the
news I was watching c-span I was
watching cable news right after 9/11 and
I remember being very surprised to hear
Democrats namely Joe Biden there were
several other Democrats they were all
being interviewed by news interviews
after after 9/11 and everyone was saying
what are we going to do how can you
decide this what do we do and actually
they were saying Joe Biden it was
especially strong we have to go after
Iraq Iraq is the first thing we have to
tear down and I wish I had a tape of
that I used to tape shows when I was in
Korea so that I'd be able to listen to
them whenever I we had such such a few
ways of getting news then I taped them I
wish I did that because I know that I
remember very very clearly that Joe
Biden and other Democrats were saying
Iraq is a problem we have to take down
Iraq and then Brian the other thing I
wanted to say was I know you
use a lorry Melroy or I know whether I'm
pronouncing her name correctly Bush
versus the Beltway I don't know whether
it was a book note or whether it was on
your program but she she maintains that
there were Iraqi Secret Service people
that were involved in the Oklahoma City
bombing and she has and she was actually
involved in government I don't remember
her positions but I wish Erik would
would try to investigate the bush versus
the Beltway book and her name and talk
with her because I believe there is
evidence that Iraq has been heavily
involved in terrorism in this country
and okay thanks Connor
miss Miller I was not interviewed on
book notes nor have I ever interviewed
or met her she was on our Colin show a
couple of times and I think she's
associated with his American Enterprise
Institute I have read her book she's
also associated with the committee for
the present danger and who which is a
group of an umbrella group for many of
the people who were involved in planning
on the war there were a quote inside and
outside the government um you know if
Joe Biden supported the war I guess I
don't disagree that he did he was misled
by the same manipulated intelligence
that so many Americans were misled by
which is why 70 percent of Americans
thought that saw him insane had some
involvement with 9/11 and nearly 50
percent thought that the hijackers were
erect let me ask you then about this
election and John Kerry who has not
repudiated his vote for the war do you
think people have a choice when it comes
to this war situation if they vote for
John Kerry over George Bush I'm very
nervous about this I'm very angry at
Kerry and his people for the attitude
why are they doing they've taken it I
talked to them about this they're doing
it I think you know the part of it is
that Kerry has a position which he
apparently believes I was at a meeting
with John Kerry that's been written up a
few times that took place at Al
Franken's living room where 17 of us on
the record questioned John Kerry as as
tough as we could it was played on the
record it was very impressive
performance and it actually made me into
someone who had a great deal more
confidence
I had going in I don't know any other
candidate that would have stood up to 17
journalists asking questions with no
rules whatsoever on the record and he
began with an argument between me and
carry on his vote for the war which I
thought was a terrible mistake now he
insists he didn't vote for the war he
insists that at the time that he voted
to give the president the authority to
go to war should it be necessary that
the president was giving every
indication that he didn't intend to go
to war that he was going to let the UN
drive the process that Brent Scowcroft
who now admits that the war was a
terrible mistake even though he ended up
supporting it he posted it first
was making speech as a Colin Powell was
sounding a very different tune and Karim
was misled by the president's apparent
willingness to use the UN rather than go
to war in opposition to the entire world
now given that it seems to me and he
said to me he turned to me during
argument he say Eric if you believe that
we'd be at war right now if I were
president then you shouldn't vote for me
and okay I believe we wouldn't be at war
now if John Kerry were president now it
seems to me John Kerry has a very easy
opening to say look I was misled by this
president just like you were and I'm
damn angry about it but now that we're
in Iraq we can't cut and run we have
responsibilities we made this mess we
have to do what we can to clean it up
but the war in Iraq was unnecessary it's
a diversion just as Richard Clarke and
Anthony Zinni and all these other people
have said said version from the war on
terrorism and I wouldn't want to win the
war on terrorism which George Bush has
abdicated responsibility for he pulled
people out of Afghanistan to go into a
rocky Osama bin Laden got away because
we weren't focusing on Afghanistan we
were too worried about this
non-threatening Iraq it's supposed to
Greta's application of presidential
responsibility imaginable Eric Alterman
who will be with us still top of the air
then we'll be joined by John putt [ __ ]
it's the job report is out a hundred and
forty-four thousand new jobs that's
6,000 below what some of the experts
were predicting unemployment rate went
down from five point five to five point
four
but the story says the drop in jobless
rate in August came as people left the
workforce for any number of reasons the
Labor Department reported on Friday we
go to Cary North Carolina and go ahead
please hi there
little example about unfiltered media
last night on CNBC on Kudlow and kramer
Kudlow ends the program really deviously
by saying george bush graduate of in
Dover of Yale of Harvard School of
Business most educated president we have
had in the history of the United States
that is insane he's perhaps the most
school he's certainly not the most
educated well it's not the most Woodrow
Wilson Woodrow Wilson was a professor
PhD in jeopardy with much smarter than
anyone oh yeah let's toast oh this it's
false it's false an awful lot of what
you I mean I get you know because I
write altercation on MSNBC I get
hundreds of emails every day saying this
guy on hardball or or O'Reilly said
something that was false and why don't
you correct it's impossible there is no
there is no respect for the idea of
truth and in cable chitchat TV and I got
a call this morning they the car
understand me wants us sitting here to
correct misstatements every time
somebody makes it David Brock he's a
liberal now he used to be conservative
he's doing that for conservatives he's
not do it for liberals I admit liberals
do it - they're not on as much they
don't have as much power they don't have
their own shows but it happens but if
you want to if you want a sort of police
of tips to find where the the discourse
is police in terms of truth I would
check out that website I think it's
called Media Matters calm that's the
only place I know where it gets done
quinoa quinoa Florida you're next George
Bush supporter how are you this morning
very good how are you good go ahead I
have a couple of points first I want to
preempt Eric Alterman on domestic policy
that Bush right now at the bounce in the
economy and the jobs albeit which are
under what he projected exactly where
Clinton was in the same category when
the year was elected by a landslide but
I want to go to a couple of foreign
policy points what do you mean in the
same category I don't understand in
other words to down from the economy and
the amount of jobs created is exactly
where they'll in fact it's about where
Bill Clinton was when he was elected in
a landslide how do you figure that
well Clinton created something like 30
million jobs over the not clean created
but 30 million or so new jobs were
created during the clinton istration the
Bush administration has been a net
negative so what's the
criteria I don't get the jobs created
during the Clinton administration all
collapsed and tanked lynda.com but you
said but no but you just said something
you just made a statement that I assume
you must have some evidence for what's
the evidence the evidence is when Bill
Clinton was elected president prior to
being president of the United States but
other government does is what every
liberal does they they take a fact
that's made ask for evidence stone oh
can I finish my point because you're in
the vein of the Michael Moore's and and
the others like like you on the left who
will post footnotes which are third for
party footnotes you'll distort facts and
then sit there with some kind of
intellectual superiority or imperative
and and act as if your word is law what
the reality prior to Bill Clinton being
elected for a second term he has done
exactly what George Bush had done with
regards to the economy and with regards
to job creation in his first term so
let's get this let's get it straight why
don't you just say I'm making it up cuz
that's what you're doing you're making
it up and you're attacking my character
because you haven't cited a single
syllable of evidence but go ahead make
up something else I just checked the
record Bill Clinton's under Bill Clinton
administration 30 million jobs were
created under George Bush's job there's
been a net decrease of X million jobs
that's the recognize first of all that
has not been a net decrease and yes
there's certainly a sir
Bill Clinton was never faced with
something like 9/11 attack whenever Bill
Clinton had the option to use the
military he would use the military until
there was a bump in the road and then he
would turn to and run but let's segue
into the foreign policy point okay so so
let's just let's just let's just capture
that moment for a second no evidence
okay what's the next point in Somalia
and there was a skirmish over the course
of a couple of days instead of
reinforcing the troops with the the
Pakistani and UN forces
Bill Clinton yanked American forces out
of the region and the last one hundreds
of thousands of people to be slaughtered
by warlords there's evidence on the
record there now let's go to foreign
policy again in one of the sort facts
you were not in the Situation Room of
the White House nor were you in the Oval
Office when the president was briefed on
Iraq's involvement I for one in glad
that we've got a president that is
taking awarded them because had the
president not taken
Rock and and had Iraq sold dirty dirty
bombs and weapons of mass destruction
which I believe Saddam Hussein had in
which I believe he would have sold and
we would have been attacked again in our
soil people like you on the Left would
have been screaming from the top of the
Empire State Building how the president
ignored it to keep the oil companies in
business over there you guys destroy the
position to to magnify the facts in
favor of the point of view that you want
you guys have the left has no interest
in truth the left has no interest in
protecting this country and the
interesting thing is that Democrats in
vain Harry Truman and Franklin Delano
Roosevelt were patriotic the left your
generation of left mr. Alterman has
become unpatriotic and in fact
subversive and in no one saying it and
what you guys do is you you exercise
your interrupt by intimidation if
anything IQs thank you got the point
I like that speech better in the
original german I think um look I'm not
gonna respond to any of that that was
that was I mean again I kept waiting for
the piece of evidence that was gonna
support any of that there wasn't any of
it he he he the gentleman made a number
of allegations which we now know to be
false there were no there were none of
these weapons there if I had to write
down this phrase because I can never
remember weapons of mass production
related program activities so we went
from he's going to attack us
tomorrow we know he's got the weapons
we're absolutely 1% short he's got the
weapons if we don't attack him tomorrow
there's gonna be an a-bomb over New York
to something called weapons of mass
production related program activities
now this gentleman who I think
represents the conservative mindset
quite well I'm glad we gave him all that
time I don't think I could do a better
job than that he's still insisted that
the original claims made by Bush and
Cheney we're somehow true even though
they've been discredited by the
administration myself the administration
admits in the fine print that those are
all false and yet he used them to impugn
my patriotism to call me a bad person in
a bad American cows Minh Texas you're on
with Eric Alterman go ahead please hi
I'm an 8-year veteran marine I'm out now
I've been out for years
I'm a Yellow Dog Democrat
the point I want to make is that their
break keeps bringing up Clinton and
about him lying he was impeached for
lying under oath not for lying not for
heaven that America extramarital affair
she was impeached for lying under oath
when President Bush had the opportunity
to testify the 9/11 Commission not only
did he refused to be sworn in he had to
take Cheney in with him
basically the recovery cover his
backside the my point is is that if he
gets called on any lies he told he'll
just say what was for the good of
country and I'm sorry
going he won't say I'm sorry he doesn't
do that and but he won't be impeached
because he wasn't under oath yeah thanks
car uh two quick points I think that it
was a really symbol of a sick it was a
symbol of a sick political culture that
a man was called to testify president
genocide was called to testify in his
sex life under oath I don't think you
should have lied under oath I think that
was a bad idea I wish I hadn't done it
but the very fact that he was there
after a 70 million dollar McCarthyite
investigation of his sex life troubles
me a great deal more than the fact that
can I ask you a question that moment it
had been a conservative who had done the
same thing basically stood out and said
you know I didn't have sex with that
woman do you think liberals would have
stood back and said oh that's okay we
don't really care about right yeah well
first of all it's true liberals don't
really care about what people do I know
they let's say they don't let's just say
they don't but do you think they in the
political system they would have just
let Ryan the Conservatives drive the
political system that was the Republican
Congress that did it they're there there
is there was it was Fox's Republican
Congress a cable news radio network
Kenneth Starr who was a Republican
loyalist who who had actually filed a
brief against Clinton before he was
appointed to that position
the Liberals don't fight this way um in
some days I wish they would but they
don't the Conservatives are much nastier
and much tougher and much more willing
to manipulate the system now on the
question of of Bush lying I think Bush
has admitted that he's lied if you pay
careful attention if he says they have
weapons of mass destruction and they
will use them unless we attack them for
which is what he said and then he says
they have not weapons of mass
destruction but weapons of mass
destruction related program activities
he's admitting that what he told you was
false he just doesn't have the courage
to be man enough to actually in a minute
running out of time for Eric Alterman
Socrates New York go ahead please yes
good morning
you know mr. alderman you're saying that
there's no proof and there's no facts
concerning weapons of mass destruction I
was in the hospital and I watched before
the war or were laying in a hospital bed
and I remember
and it was on record there were
videotapes that I'm showing Sodom was
saying moving trucks every night night
after night you don't suppose he was
loading Sodapop on those trucks do you
moving them - all the difference before
the 9/11 Commission we're gone before we
got there
and has proved from the satellite
pictures that show that he was moving
stuff out he didn't move any other
weapons we found all of those in schools
and other places all over and I also
want to tell you that I have relatives
who over in Iraq and they moved in on
those training camps and they saw in
those training camps that al-qaeda had
been training in those camps they
weren't just military camps for him to
train his own personnel and so you're
saying it's not on the record but 9/11
report even said quote that Iraq had
some ties with al-qaeda some how do you
define that and what how much is some
and but the point is they showed
pictures of bin Laden going to Iraq
constantly and as far as the Swift Boat
ads are concerned sir you're not really
watching them because they're not just
talking about his hero record well while
he was in the war they also talked about
what he did when he came home from the
war and my fiance was a PLW in Iraq at
the time and he came home and even
before this political thing is later
started with him wanting to be President
I can remember him heartbreakingly
telling me about how they played over
and over and over again to get them to
sign papers that they were animals and
they were guilty of what Carrie was
accusing them all right thank you for
calling let me take a call because
before we run out of time with the last
call for this this hour let's go to a
long Long Island New York here our last
call go ahead and cut its liabilities
and
starts to hold political debate are
using books like yours and crimes
against nature and stuff the only thing
is I was wondering where should I post
this information because I really think
that if people believe in issues are you
know understand issues they will they
will see how much better carrier is done
good thanks
got that got her point and then the last
point was last comment from you yeah I'm
sorry I had a little trouble
understanding their last look the the
the lady who called from Saugerties what
she's saying was just false and and the
problem and it's been it's been the Bush
administration doesn't even say there
anymore except they hint at it because
they know it's false but they won't come
out and say it
the 9/11 Commission which had access to
all the classified data repudiated Colin
Powell has apologized to the country for
giving false information to try to
convince us go to War II in his UN
presentation what about her point though
that her husband was a POWs she said it
actually meant Vietnam and that these
kind of comments were being filtered
back in through the prisons by the
Vietnamese that's true and that's
unfortunate and that's one of the
problems that you have in a democracy
where the things you say when you tell
your people the truth other people get
to hear it too but the truth of that is
that our leaders Democratic leaders at
first and then Republican leaders made a
terrible mistake in Vietnam and John
Kerry I think showed great courage in
going there and then coming back and
trying to save his comrades from that
same mistake if only George Bush and
Dick Cheney had showed the same kind of
courage for a war that they in fact
supported then they would have a much
stronger argument about character this
is Eric Alderman's new book soon to be
in the bookstores called when President
sly a history of official deception it's
and its consequences from FDR to George
W Bush thank you very much thank you
Brian it's been a pleasure once again
John putt hearts and Justin